currently today training Kings Christian
Business Network is the largest
Christian business network in Europe and
you know we've got 14 branches across
the country and I really just want to
acknowledge a certain person today
there's this one person within training
kings I first saw our conference names
Fran
Francesca McDowell I saw her a big
conference and she was kind of like
heading up managing it organizing it I
just I remember just looking here in or
thinking wow you know I want to be
around somebody like that I need someone
like that in my life in my team
she's a little bit scary but she's got a
big heart and I became friends with
Francesca and Francesca believed in the
training King's vision it's a couple
years ago now and she set up a branch of
her own morva Hampton grew to be a big
trend in Kings branch more than the 14
and she started to change things and
manage things and basically she just
started running the show and I just took
a back seat and watched it grow and
watch the fruit and everything like that
and Francesca is here today and
officially as from this week I've made
her director of training Kings
[Applause]
Wow Wow some of you remember Francesca
from from yesterday she was in a crew
talk you wow you look good you look
different
all we needed to share chat I noticed
what we didn't like we didn't plan this
so anything particularly I just said to
a literal I said to a last night you're
coming back to motions and I'm busy I
said finally can you just stop by for 10
minutes and I want to honor you and I
want to acknowledge you all I'm gonna be
taking a back seat a little bit all I'm
having my baby Amanda I see I just want
to honor you and would you share five
minutes and I think I said that could
you just share a couple minutes just let
the girls know what you're doing what's
on your heart and you know what really
just to inspire other people because as
I said when I started training Kings it
was just and now it's like and Fran made
it happen so I really think she deserves
a few minutes so Francesca over to you
baby girl thank you good afternoon
everybody it's a delight to be here
again with you as Samuel said the
journey with in training Kings has been
incredible it's changed my life it's
changed so many people's life because
there's a time when we can separate
ourselves when we have faith over there
and you know it's what we do on a Sunday
and Bible study and then our business is
what we do Monday to Friday but the
reality is we are who we are 24/7 so to
bring a faith and your work together it
makes sense but it's not been the norm
so within training Kings you know our
mission statement is to inspire and
equip Christians to be successful in
business
yeah but we're inclusive so one of my
favorite memories with in training Kings
is of a Sikh lady coming coming to one
of our breakfast meetings sitting in the
room and everybody gets a chance to
stand up for one minute and introduce
themselves well Herman it was five
minutes why because she began to share
her heart her heart for why she was in
business so it wasn't just to make money
and do well but it was actually to raise
funds to push back into some charity
work in India and as she shared she
began to cry and she said I've never
been in such an environment what I have
felt say
enough to share my vision and I was like
wow what a privilege that we have to
create environments in which people can
be true to themselves and be around
like-minded individuals who get them
because that's what we want in life
isn't it
people who get us but not just getting
us as then inspiring us to get to the
that next level
and within training things like Samuel
said across the country we've got
branches and I get to meet people week
in week out who have a vision and it
might just be here or it might be kind
of something that they feel I want to do
it I don't know how and to witness their
journey from a vision or an idea or no
idea into something that then bears
fruit they get their company name they
register their company name they get a
logo they get a business plan and before
you know it they're they're standing
there in confidence talking about their
business from pretty much nothing
so within training Kings we really
provide opportunities for people to grow
to get educated and to also just spell
some of the myths around faith and money
who here grew up with the whole belief
that money's evil anybody else had that
understanding a few of you in the room
and you can almost feel a little bit
awkward or uncomfortable to to make a
lot of money or to be successful and
there's a bit of a contradiction between
can I be a Christian and be a good and
godly person and still be successful in
business but yet the two go hand in hand
because what we do is actually within
our businesses within our lives it
glorifies God for me a successful in it
and it changes people's lives this
morning we had a wall we had double
vamped and breakfast and one of the
ladies she stood up and she said there's
two people who I met through training
Kings and they're transformed my
business and my vision and she named
them and she spoke about what they had
done to really bring about so much
change and that's just one example
people make connections and they meet
other people as well
so I just wanted in you know encourage
you if you are a Christian in business
if you're not a Christian in business
but you're looking for like money people
join in what we do we get emails and
calls from people all over the country
had guy from Northern Ireland the other
day is there one in my area I want to be
involved with what you're involved in
because it's an incredible platform if
you have a vision run with it if you
have an idea
do it could the world is waiting for you
there's not another one of you you
unique and you're special and you're
gifted so don't hold back be your best
you thank you and god bless you
[Applause]